Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
As facial reenactment videos are improving
at a rapid pace, it is getting easier and
easier to create video impersonations of other
people by transferring our gestures onto their
faces.
We have recently discussed a technique that
is able to localize the modified regions within
these videos, however, this technique was
limited to human facial reenactment.
That is great, but what about the more general
case with manipulated photos?
Well, do not worry for second, because this
new learning-based algorithm can look at any
image and highlight the regions that were
tampered with.
It can detect image splicing, which means
that we take part of a different image and
add it to this one.
Or, copying an object and pasting it into
the image elsewhere.
Or, removing an object from a photo and filling
in the hole with meaningful information harvested
from the image.
This we also refer to as image inpainting,
and this is something that we also use often
to edit our thumbnail images that you see
here on YouTube.
Believe it or not, it can detect all of these
cases.
And it uses a two-stream convolutional neural
network to accomplish this.
So what does this mean exactly?
This means a learning algorithm that looks
at one, the color data of the image to try
to find unnatural contrast changes along edges
and silhouettes, and two, the noise information
within the image as well and see how they
relate to each other.
Typically, if the image has been tampered
with, either the noise, or the color data
is disturbed, or, it may also be that they
look good one by one, but the relation of
the two has changed.
The algorithm is able to detect these anomalies
too.
As many of the images we see on the internet
are either resized or compressed, or both,
it is of utmost importance that the algorithm
does not look at compression artifacts and
thinks that the image has been tampered with.
This is something that even humans struggle
with on a regular basis, and this is luckily
not the case with this algorithm.
This is great because a smart attacker may
try to conceal their mistakes by recompressing
an image and thereby adding more artifacts
to it.
It's not going to fool this algorithm.
However, as you Fellow Scholars pointed out
in the comments of a previous episode, if
we have a neural network that is able to distinguish
forged images, with a little modification,
we can perhaps turn it around and use it as
a discriminator to help training a neural
network that produces better forgeries.
What do you think about that?
It is of utmost importance that we inform
the public that these tools exist.
If you wish to hear more about this topic,
and if you think that a bunch of videos like
this a month is worth a dollar, please consider
supporting us on Patreon.
You know the drill, a dollar a month is almost
nothing, but it keeps the papers coming.
Also, for the price of a coffee, you get exclusive
early access to every new episode we release,
and there are even more perks on our Patreon
page, patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers.
We also support cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin,
Ethereum and Litecoin, the addresses are available
in the video description.
With your help, we can make better videos
in the future.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!